là monsieur bonsoir la grève des
infirmières reconduite jusqu'à lundi
quels que soient les résultats des
négociations ce soir le premier ministre
s'exprime sur les salaires une première
en corse l'assemblée régionale vote une
motion qui affirment l'identité
culturelle du peuple corse comme le
demande depuis longtemps les
nationalistes antenne 2 au sommet
l'everest conti ce matin par
l'expédition sagarmatha 10h30 ce matin à
paris au dessus des champs elysées un
avion un monomoteur blanc serait à
nouveau le fameux baron noir
le héros du feuilleton de l'été qui
narguait les autorités en survolant la
capitale alors que c'est strictement
interdite albert maltret sous
surveillance policière depuis des
semaines était bien ce matin l'homme qui
pilotait l'avion il a été interpellé
mais s'agit-il vraiment du baron noir
patrice pollet six pilotes c'était moi
je pense
on sort et on le serait jeune et je ne
cache jamais ce que je fais j'ai déjà
payé très cher mon atterrissage sur les
champs elysées je pense que si un jour
je recommence je sais ce que je risque
et cette fois ci ce sera la prison si je
me faisais prendre et puis une amende
mais je crois peut-être pas payer mais
toute façon je n'ai pas encore réfléchi
au problème actuellement voilà ce que
déclarait maltret en août de cette année
alors que dans le ciel de paris des
centaines de guetteur chercher le baron
noir en tout cas ce matin maltret a
récidivé et s'est fait pincer à 10h30 il
décolle d'ici de cette piste de
l'aérodrome de saint cyr il est aux
commandes de cet avion un rallye
monomoteur baptisé affectueusement
l'épave
compte tenu de son avantage un quart
d'heure plus tard à 10h45 maltret est au
dessus des champs elysées et j'ai vu un
peu venir un petit avion de l'arc de
triomphe
allant vers l'eau bénie
quelle altitude et volé au très bas très
très bas et 10h54 maltret de retour mais
il a été repéré pendant son vol
le comité d'accueil l'attend à sa tête
le commissaire cool bois lui a dit qu'il
en est et ce qu'on venait faire
interpeller en disant que c'était lui
qui avait survolé paris ce matin et nous
avions dans un premier temps contre lui
a dit qu'il avait été remarqué par xe
services de police et a fini par dire
oui c'est immense mois qui viennent
seront ce matin maltret était bien aux
commandes mais qui survolait paris cet
été
l'intéressé n'a pas reconnu être le
baron noir et aucune charge ne pèse pour
le moment sur lui dans cette affaire
arrive-t-il de l'être alors là la
réponse est oui
regardez bien cette photo c'était il ya
huit jours maltret se faisait
photographier déguisé en baron noir
elles étaient venues de partout par cars
par trains spéciaux pour exiger dans les
rues de paris
un statut et de meilleurs salaires les
infirmières ont manifesté en masse
aujourd'hui à l'appel de la coordination
et de la cgt qui avait organisé le plus
gros cortège à l'appel aussi de
l'intersyndicale qui manifestaient
séparément
le ministre de la santé claude evin
continue en ce moment de négocier avec
les syndicats mais déjà la coordination
qu'il avait rencontré plus tôt dans
l'après-midi appelle à la poursuite de
la grève jusqu'à lundi
françois joly et christophe martet dix
élèves infirmières
les infirmières confirmé et même des
professeurs de renom comme léon
schaffhauser michel boisrond pour les
soutenir
elle était ce matin à paris près de
100000 venus de toute la france à
l'appel de la coordination des
infirmières
oui
les syndicats eux n'ont pas réussi leur
pari faire aussi bien que la
coordination des infirmières tout
personnel hospitalier confondues dix
mille personnes seulement ont défilé cet
après-midi de la coordination dans cette
mobilisation ce que nous reprochons à la
coordination fait de ne s'intéresser
qu'aux seuls actionnaires les l'hôpital
n'est pas de servir les infirmières
c'est aussi six cent cinquante mille
autres personnels 14h30 claude evin en
personne reçoit les dirigeants de la
coordination
il précise les propositions de ces
derniers jours une augmentation de 500
francs pour les infirmières en début de
carrière avec à terme une revalorisation
de leur salaire de 1000 francs à sa
sortie la coordination adopte un ton
mesuré la pression qui s'exerce
actuellement au niveau du du mouvement
infirmier a considérablement fait
progresser les choses
ceci étant dit rien n'est figé pour
l'instant mais la base elle ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille
très mobilisés en fin d'après midi les
manifestants ont décidé la poursuite du
mouvement de grève pour demain et samedi
depuis un peu plus d'une heure ce soir
ici au ministère de la santé les
négociations ont repris entre les
syndicats et le ministre claude evin
les syndicats attendent les ultimes
propositions du ministre le gouvernement
lui semble décidé à aller très vite
maintenant pour éteindre ce conflit
avant qu'il ne se propage à toutes les
professions de la santé et le premier
ministre pourrait recevoir lui-même ce
soir une délégation des infirmiers
venait signer pour les enseignants les
militants du syndicat national de
l'enseignement secondaire et cinq autres
syndicats de la fon faisait l'article
devant les grands magasins à paris à
l'heure du déjeuner une manière
originale d'en appeler à la sympathie de
l'opinion avant la grève annoncée dans
l'enseignement secondaire pour le 20
octobre prochain
le syndicat national des lycées et
collèges a rejoint le mouvement
au coeur des revendications là aussi
l'amélioration des salaires et d'une
condition que beaucoup jugent
dévaloriser claire chazal 20 ans de
carrière depuis 20 ans jocelyne beffara
accueille chaque matin ses petits élèves
de l'école du boulevard de belleville et
la vocation peut appeler ça comme ça
oui j'aime beaucoup même occuper les
enfants m
il expliquait notation
vous n'auriez pas fait autre chose non
absolument pas toujours mais une sorte
de sacerdoce aussi pour jocelyne avec un
traitement de 8400 francs par mois à 40
ans et l'espoir de gagner tout juste dix
mille francs fin de carrière après 37
ans de travail
je pense que c'est un peu plus difficile
qu'avant disons je peux partir un mois
on va penser que je paye moi même
entièrement made est hors de question de
partir à 4 personnes à l'étranger
seulement c'est pas dans nos moyens
financiers et par exemple acheter un
appartement c'est difficile aussi ça
c'est impossible dans le film en
primaire il n'y a plus d'homme
bien sûr parce que notre salaire n'est
qu'un salaire d'appoint et c'est très
difficile pour une famille d'avoir enfin
le père instituteur etc les plus
suffisant les gens ne nous considèrent
plus vraiment comme des gens importants
on n'a plus la place qu'on devait être
qu'on avait avant un bon et ça passe
aussi par une revalorisation du salaire
parce qu'ils ont l'énorme responsabilité
de tracer l'avenir des enfants
les trois cent mille instituteurs
s'estime en droit aujourd'hui d'attendre
davantage de la société le travail a
repris presque normalement aujourd'hui
dans les usines renault
le conflit hier soir à l'atelier du mans
avait été réglé mais des débrayages ont
eu lieu à nouveau à l'appel de la cfdt
et de la cgt les syndicats sont
mécontents des dernières propositions
salariales de la régie un chiffre qui a
presque l'alluré d'une bonne nouvelle la
hausse des prix en septembre a été de
0,2 pour cent un peu moins élevé qu'en
nous mais le gouvernement reste vigilant
le climat social est difficile du
commerce extérieur pèse sur le front et
il faudrait que la baisse des prix du
pétrole agissent dans bon sens sur l'
indice des prix un mauvais chiffre celui
du déficit commercial américain en forte
augmentation à 12,2 milliards de dollars
73 millions de francs
le cours du dollar baisse les taux
d'intérêt sont à la hausse et ce n'est
pas bon pour le franc
les conflits sociaux mais aussi les
débordement des syndicats par la base
dans le cas des infirmières c'est le
thème qui a dominé la réunion du comité
central du parti communiste aujourd'hui
bruno roger petit
le parti communiste veut remonter
remonter ses résultats électoraux en
remontant en première ligne des conflits
sociaux
gardiens de prisons agents de la ratp
infirmières les communistes entendent
soutenir tous ses mouvements
quant à l'apparition de coordination
spontanée qui dépasse le cadre
traditionnel des syndicats
georges marchais n'en est pas à
perturber alors voyez cette cette idée
de coordination
elle est pour une part la la réponse à
une volonté unitaire mais c'est
précisément notre politique et c'est
précisément
moi j'ai dû bien tous les documents de
la cgt la politique de la cgt qu'un
conflit social soit gérée par une
coordination spontanée ou un syndicat
traditionnels peu importe le parti
communiste être présent très présent le
parti communiste dira oui au référendum
calédonien même réponse du côté des
adhérents directs de l'udf à la veille
du conseil national du parti qui se
prononcera officiellement demain le
nouvel observateur que vit un premier
sondage à propos de ce référendum
d'après la sofres 63% des personnes
interrogées n'ont pas l'intention
d'aller voter
parmi les votants 80 2 % voteraient oui
le front national lui prédit une
majorité de non au référendum et fait
campagne dans ce sens mais c'est pour le
rétablissement de la peine de mort que
les militants de ce parti manifester
tout à leur place de l'opéra à paris
ils réclamaient donc le rétablissement
de la peine de mort pour les assassins
la manifestation s'est déroulée dans le
calme et sans incident les banques se
font taper sur les doigts
les conseils de la concurrence a enjoint
aujourd'hui le groupement d'intérêt
économique carte bancaire de modifier
ses règles de fonctionnement
à l'origine de ce rappel à l'ordre une
plainte du conseil national du commerce
à propos des tarifs véronique auger
véritable coup de semences ou bien coup
d'épée dans l'eau
certes désormais les banques n'auront
plus le droit de fixer entre elles le
tarif minimum de la carte bancaire
certes les commerçants verseront
maintenant une cotisation plus ou moins
élevé selon qu'ils sont ou non équipés
de systèmes contre la fraude
mais comme pour le prix de la baguette
il faudra sans doute attendre avant que
la concurrence ne produisent un effet
durable sur les tarifs des cartes
je pense qu'il ne serait pas raisonnable
de penser que la suppression de ce
minimum doivent entraîner un abaissement
du prix de la carte parce que il y aura
immanquablement à terme une diminution
de la qualité du produit
la grande crainte du groupement cartes
bancaire
c'est justement de voir arriver d'autres
réseaux étrangers plus performant le
conseil national de la concurrence a
lui-même creusé la première brèche ce
matin en autorisant les banques qui
proposent des cartes bancaires à vendre
des euros chèque
le vote de l'assemblée régionale fera
date dans l'histoire de la corse pour la
première fois la nuit dernière les élus
de droite et les socialistes ont voté
ensemble à une large majorité une motion
qui affirme l'existence d'une communauté
historique et culturelle vivante
regroupant les corses
cette reconnaissance qui appelaient de
leurs voeux les nationalistes fait
sauter l'un des verrous qui bloquaient
le dialogue politique dans l'île
alors comment réagit-on au village
dominique verdeilhan deux heures ce
matin à l'assemblée de corse
moment historique l'assemblée affirme
l'existence du peuple corse l'énergie
ont voté contre
le pc n'a pas voté la motion déposée par
les nationalistes a créé l'union qui ne
s'était pas produite en 83
à vingt kilomètres d'ajaccio le village
de cot ulli corticchiato la rumeur ci
est vite propagé mais les langues se
délient difficilement à la surprise
succès de la satisfaction de voir près
officialisé un état d'esprit ce n'est
que la reconnaissance de ce que nous
sommes un peuple corse avec pas
seulement corse tout le monde tous les
gens qui travaillent chez nous c'est
très bien c'est que vient il était temps
moi à la campagne mais quand même quand
tu es quand leur comme il sait qu'il
existe nous on verra ça à l'application
c'est à dire que on sera très vigilants
c'est pas uniquement une décision de
principe qui peut faire changer les
choses
en toile de fond de cette reconnaissance
la langue corse qui est enseigné dans ce
village ont séduit déjà la langue aux
pieds moment pas un théâtre par les
continents faim de tout ce qu'on veut
pas par des leçons systématiques sont
heureusement pas un bon mois ce n'est
pas nous
j'ai toujours parlé corse une neuvième
victime découverte aujourd'hui à nîmes
la neuvième victime des inondations qui
ravagent est la ville il ya dix jours en
côte d'or un adolescent recherché depuis
hier après midi a été retrouvé mort dans
le canal rhin-rhône emporté sans doute
par les pluies diluviennes qui s'étaient
abattues sur la région
on s'attend à de nouvelles chutes de
pluie dans le sud est du pays avant 48
heures manifestation ce soir à paris en
solidarité avec l'algérie sosracisme
différents syndicats des organisations
humanitaires ont rejoint une
coordination de solidarité créée par des
algériens en france plusieurs milliers
de personnes étaient au rendez vous
alger la journée a été calme
il ne reste plus dans la ville que
quelques blindés les magasins sont mieux
approvisionner les incidents qui ont eu
lieu hier à tizi ouzou n'ont fait que
deux blessés légers contrairement aux
informations qui circulent et hier les
autorités ont libéré plusieurs personnes
connues pour leur antipathie au régime
qui avaient été arrêtés avant les
émeutes
quels sont maintenant les perspectives
werth parle annonce du prochain
référendum jacques merlino a rencontré à
alger
alia qui en font d'ailleurs du syndicat
des travailleurs algériens
le problème si vous voulez c'est
maintenant le problème qui se pose est
ce que c'est une évolution de la
situation par des réformes qui vont
rétablir la situation ou bien c'est une
transformation
c'est ça le problème capital est ce
qu'il y a remise en cause de tout le
système politique algérien ou ce qu'il
ya une évolution qui va aboutir
est ce que les algériens demandent des
demandes depuis des dizaines d'années à
ce que l'espace de liberté soit énergie
je comprends qu'ils accueillaient ce
référendum savez le référendum vous avez
sur le plan des principes c'est la
meilleure et la pire des choses
dans quelles conditions fiscales sur les
abandonne qu'est-ce qui va contourner ce
qui ne va pas avoir de fraude électorale
et il faut que les citoyens qui sont
majeurs qui sont maxime il faudrait
qu'il participe justement à ces
élections pour qu'elle soit elle se
fasse au grand jour et dont une maison
avec le gouvernement tunisien s'est
officiellement félicité aujourd'hui du
retour à la normale en algérie et
réitéré sa solidarité avec le régime
il est vrai que l'inquiétude demeure
dans les pays voisins qui connaissent
tous les mêmes symptômes
une jeunesse nombreuse est insatisfaite
un intégrisme religieux plus ou moins
agressifs une économie en difficulté
gilles rabin mars 65 20 80 jean vier 84
émeutes de la vie chère au maroc janvier
60 18 janvier 80 et 84 révolte du pain
en tunisie octobre 88 l'algérie touché à
son tour
à chaque fois et dans chacun des trois
pays le même détonateur la pénurie ou
l'augmentation brutale du prix des
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité
pain semoule huile légumes à chaque fois
les mêmes destruction sauvage la même
colère soudaine des pauvres des gourbis
et la même jeunesse désespérée du
maghreb tunisie maroc algérie à chaque
fois aussi la même réaction du pouvoir
en place qui envoie l'armée tiré sur sa
jeunesse avec à chaque fois un bilan un
peu plus lourd 120 morts en tunisie
150 au maroc 180 officiellement en
algérie
aucun des régimes politiques au pouvoir
n'a su apporter de réponse à cette
jeunesse qui représentent 60% de la
population aujourd'hui et qui réclame
partout à la fois plus de pain plus de
travail et plus de libertés l'espoir
d'un futur grand maghreb célébré ici
l'été dernier à alger par ben ali le
tunisien hassan ii le marocain chadi la
jerry ayan mauritanien herrada fit le
lit bien cette perspective d'un grand
marché commun des arabes d'afrique du
nord ne suffira pas à calmer la rage ni
le désespoir des jeunes du maghreb
après les inondations la famine au
soudan déchirée au sud par la guérilla
les souffrances de la population sont
sans limites emmanuel vanier morts de
faim plusieurs milliers de morts en
quelques mois la famine dessine les
dinka une ethnie du sud du soudan
aucune aide humanitaire aucun
ravitaillement ne leur est pas revenue
depuis six mois pas d'aéroport des
routes coupées par les inondations et
les autorités soudanaises qui ne
distribue pas des dodine cas qu'ils
accusent de grossir les rangs de la
guérilla anti gouvernementales la famine
ici est pire qu'en ethiopie le calvaire
des dinka ne s'arrête pas là ceux qui
parviennent à survivre sont réduits en
esclavage par des tribus ennemies
sommet sino soviétique l'an prochain en
chine le numéro un chinois deng xiaoping
a profité de la visite du président
finlandais pour annoncer la nouvelle
après trente ans de brouille profonde la
normalisation entre les deux géants
communiste pourrait rétablir le rôle de
puissance de la chine dans le triangle
washington moscou pékin elle lui
permettrait également de garantir une
paix durable sur ses 7500 km de
frontière commune avec l'ours est donc
de donner la priorité à sa
reconstruction économique
deuxième et dernier débat dans quelques
heures aux états unis entre les deux
candidats à la présidence le républicain
george bush et le démocrate michael
dukakis un débat qui aura lieu en
californie le plus importante étant en
matière électorale
un état où michael dukakis doit
absolument marquer des points s'il veut
gagner l'élection dans moins d'un mois
une tâche très difficile la californie a
voté républicain dans huit des neuf
dernières élections le débat de la
dernière chance pour michael dukakis de
fait le dernier sondage en date donnent
le républicain bush largement favori
vide juridique vient d'être comblée en
france
ou va l'être bientôt le sénat en effet a
adopté une proposition de loi sur les
expérimentations de médicaments sur
l'homme un sujet particulièrement
délicat qui n'était pas réglementé on
l'avait vu à propos des expérimentations
menées à amiens par le professeur millau
alain labouze neuf ans neuf ans que
lydia bse ces atteintes de sclérose en
plaques
pas de traitement miracle pour cette
maladie alors elle en est consciente
aucun véritable espoir de guérison pour
le moment pourtant depuis le début de
l'année elle participe à un essai pilote
avec un nouveau médicament peut être
efficace quand on souffre de sclérose en
plaques
on est prêt à tout y compris à jouer les
cobayes 10 kilowatts heure qui est
angoissante très angoissante
il ya des moments où on est des frigos
160 parce que c'est pas si demain on va
paralyser si ça va passer les poussières
et de secours se réveille la veille
connais bien le lendemain on a une
paralysie je veux tout j'accepte tout
pourvu que je vis rif et on irait vin
parce que les chercheurs sont très bons
pas question cependant d'abuser du
désespoir de certains malades pour voir
expérimenté n'importe quelles molécules
pour ces malades hospitalisés ici dans
un service de neurologie
c'est bien souvent la famille qui devra
donner son feu vert pour
l'expérimentation de nouveaux
médicaments
nous avons des problèmes difficiles
lorsque des patients sont hospitalisés
en urgence pour les accidents brutaux et
ses patients ont souvent un coma ou un
trouble de la conscience et nous
demandons alors à la famille
de signer ou d'accepter le principe d'un
essai médicamenteux et là c'est sacré de
l' angoisse car il faut simultanément
faire hospitaliser le patient accepter
le stress que représente cette
hospitalisation et en même temps prendre
une décision qui peut être
grave ou significatives pour l'avenir du
patient jusqu'à présent les essais de
médicaments sur l'homme se faisait dans
la plus parfaite illégalité avec la
proposition de loi votée par le sénat
c'est la fin d'une époque celle des
expérimentations sauvage revenons
maintenant aux conflits sociaux en
france et aux revendications salariales
qui se multiplient le premier ministre
qui doit poursuivre ses entretiens avec
les différents syndicats via deux
lancers à l'instant sur tf1 une mise en
garde contre tout dérapage des salaires
sur ce point les choses sont bien
claires
autant il est les infirmières sur le cas
typique des cas particuliers de métier
sous qualifiés ou mal reconnus c'était
net dans le cas des infirmières et d'une
certaine façon c'était aussi le cas des
raisonnements faire des gardiens de
l'administration pénitentiaire pour le
reste il faut faire tout le possible
mais ne pas prendre le risque de
relancer la hausse des prix l'inflation
et l'usure du pouvoir d'achat parce que
la hausse des prix court toujours plus
vite
alors j on prend le risque en ce moment
j'ai quand même la joie de vous dire que
comme des choses s'accélèrent un peu en
allemagne le mouvement des prix en
france est parfaitement sain et que nous
sommes parmi les plus bas d'europe
c'est ce qui donne sa réalité à toute
augmentation de salaire qui est du
pouvoir d'achat réel
rennes ne quittons pas cette situation
nous ne pouvons marcher qu'à ce pas là
c'est à dire que rattraper des retards
pris ou corriger des injustices ne peut
se faire que dans le respect de ses
grands équilibres et autant je ferais je
le disais tout à l'heure
l'impossible pour que les infirmières se
sentent reconnus bien placés dans cette
société qui leur doit leur place et pour
ce faire les rémunérer mieux puisqu'elle
avait été sous reconnu sourd et muet
c'est incontestable autant dire me
généraux même si je reconnais qu'il y a
du rattrapage
donnons-nous un peu de temps faisons une
programmation et donnons nous rendez
vous pour un bilan au milieu de l'année
prochaine une première réaction à chaud
propos du premier ministre celle du
secrétaire général de la cfdt
monsieur maire bonsoir bonsoir alors que
pensez vous de cet avertissement quand
même assez ferme de michel rocard à
nouveau je pense que
le premier ministre oppose le moyen
terme ou le long terme
à court terme il dit en gros ce qu'on a
attendu depuis plus entendu depuis
plusieurs années maintenant attendez
encore un moment pour pouvoir régler vos
problèmes
or il faut bien voir c'est vrai qu'il ne
faut pas sacrifier l'avenir au présent
mais c'est vrai aussi qu'il ne faut pas
en permanence sacrifier le présent à
l'avenir
or de ce point de vue aujourd'hui il ya
des réponses urgentes nécessaires ce
soir des négociations pour les
infirmières demain dans la fonction
publique pour les agents du service
public et on ne peut pas en permanence
opposé les impératifs économiques aux
impératifs sociaux y avait un très bel
article de michel rocard il ya quelques
jours dans le monde avec d'ailleurs ce
grand quitte il faut réconcilier
l'économique et le social
eh bien ça commence en liant les projets
à moyen terme
et là je ne fais pas d'injures au
premier ministe de croire qu'il n'y en a
pas il serait certainement des projets à
moyen terme et ses projets à moyen terme
ne prennent leur sens pour ceux qui
étaient là aujourd'hui manifestants les
infirmières agents hospitaliers ou pour
ceux qui demain s'il n'ya pas
d'aboutissement des négociations
salariales réagir on vient pour cela il
faut aussi que pour le moment et dans
l'instant l'immédiat soit liée à
l'avenir à relier l'économique et le
social relier le présent et l'avenir
je crois que c'est là une gestion
équilibrée alors que pas en permanence
demander d'attendre oui mais qu'est ce
que vous pensez monsieur maire de la
méthode la méthode rocard s'était dit
régler les conflits un parent et
attendre qu'il soit mûr est-ce que vous
appréciez cette méthode là vous pensez
que c'est la bonne ou est-ce qu'il
vaudrait mieux faire une espèce de
nouveau grenelle et tout remettre à plat
en même temps faut bien voir concernant
tous les agents des services publics et
public hospitalier bien sûr l'infirmière
les techniciens une façon générale il y
as besoin de remettre à plat
administration par administration les
grille de classification voir comment on
va revaloriser et donc entamer des
négociations précise qu'ils vont
demander c'est sur un certain temps cela
c'est une bonne méthode
encore faut-il l'engager pour l'instant
elle n'a pas encore été annoncée
officiellement et c'est pourtant très
important que ce soit annoncé
mais d'autre part il y à aussi
l'immédiat l'immédiat c'est quand même
que les quand même il faut bien voir que
les
les fonctionnaires les agents des
services publics ne sont pas demandeurs
de politique qui bouleverse tous il
demande simplement que l'on rattrape
n'ont pas le pouvoir d'achat pour les
années précédentes mais uniquement pour
cette année qui est maintien du pouvoir
d'achat cette année et l'année prochaine
c'est donc des revendications je dirais
minimale qui sont très sérieuses très
responsable alors un dernier fois
monsieur le maire on voit bien notamment
avec les infirmières que les syndicats
dont le vôtre sont complètement débordés
par la base par la coordination ça ne
vous inquiète pas ce phénomène qui
serait prêt je n'appelle pas ça du tout
du débordement vous savez vous vous
aviez d'après l'estimation d'un autre
fédération il y avait aujourd'hui 15000
manifestants minimum absolument minimum
quinze à vingt mille ont à leur
rassemblement intersyndical et force
ouvrière la cgc l'insulté c'est bien y
avait donc une capacité de mobilisation
et simplement cette distinction c'est
vrai réel c'est que nous ne voulons pas
régler les problèmes des infirmières
indépendamment de ceux des autres agents
hospitaliers
je pense notamment aux soignants aux
aides soignantes aux techniciens de
laboratoires et autres ya donc souffler
une politique ces syndicats c'est pas
simplement régler les problèmes
catégorielles en oubliant les autres
c'est de relier ensemble de coordonner
c'est vrai mais de coordonner dans la
même politique une politique solidaire
l'ensemble des personnels monsieur mer
merci pour cette réaction donc aux
propos du premier ministre à l'instant
pour la première fois dans son histoire
le prix nobel de littérature a été
décerné aujourd'hui un écrivain de
langue arabe l'égyptien naguib mahfouz
maître du roman moderne et de la
nouvelle dans son pays il a été
découvert en france par la maison
d'édition sinbad et publié aussi par la
thèse sylvie marion retenu ce visage
retenez ce nom surtout naguib mahfouz
gauche cet écrivain égyptien prix nobel
88 connu de quelques spécialistes
seulement en france vaut le détour
ses romans vendus à des millions
d'exemplaires dans les pays arabes sont
pleins d'histoires truculente
universelle qui décrivent la vie des
gens aux prises avec les difficultés et
les espoirs du quotidien dans son
dans sa littérature une période
pharaonique une période plus idéologique
et une période de littérature populaire
où il se situe certains disent de entre
balzac et zola moi je dirais entre
eugène sue le grand feuilletoniste du
19e siècle et carco parce qu'il est en
même temps très vivant et très moderne
et il faut le découvrir parce que c'est
le petit peuple du ter qui parle c'est
le leem aux égyptiens le leem eaux du
nil humain qui parle ce sont les bandits
d'honneur
les mystiques elle est l'héroïne
tourneur les [ __ ] les valeurs mais
aussi les braves gens de tous les petits
quartiers du caire qui explose dans ses
livres de mille façons et c'est très
beau qu'est ce que ça représente pour
une petite maison d'édition comme la
vôtre
un prix nobel une consécration
littéraire une consultation
internationale que j'attendais depuis
vingt ans parce que il y à de très
grands écrivains de langue arabe
ils étaient oubliées et si le plus
célèbre d'entre eux est enfin couronné
en occident c'est important si la
première fois que le jury suédois
courant un auteur de langue arabe
la première fois depuis longtemps qu'ils
récompensent un romancier très populaire
lisible par tous le saint suaire est
bien un faux le vatican a mis fin
officiellement aujourd'hui un mystère
est un tabou la relique conservée à
turin depuis des siècles date en fait du
moyen-âge et sautent en utilisant la
technologie la plus moderne que les
experts avec la bénédiction du saint
siège
on peut définir la date de fabrication
du tissu patrick esther depuis plus de
deux siècles
des millions de pèlerins se sont
prosternés devant lui une pièce des tofs
longue de 4 mètres 36 ayant dix et ont
enveloppé le corps du christ à sa
descente de croix
le 21 avril l'église a autorisé le
prélèvement de trois échantillons du
tissu trois laboratoires américains
suisse et anglais ont procédé à
l'analyse de ces fragments grâce à une
technique très sophistiqués basés sur la
langue d intégration des atomes de
carbone 14 contenus dans
issu ce matin l'archevêque de turin a
rendu public les résultats tous concorde
le saint suaire a été réalisée entre
1260 et 1390 c'est donc un faux je ne
vois aucune raison a dit le cardinal de
mettre en doute ses résultats l'église
n'a jamais affirmé que le saint suaire
était une relique sainte
même si elle a accepté sa vénération en
revanche les analyses pratiquées sur les
pigments des fibres de les toffes ne
permettent pas de dire comment le
portrait du christ a été dessinée ou
peints sur le tissu certains
scientifiques se contente d'émettre une
hypothèse au moyen âge un artiste aurait
enveloppé une statue du christ dans une
étoffe en frottant de la main les
parties les plus en relief
cet artiste très noir s'ils tissu
produisant une fois les toffes déroulé
l'impression réaliste et troublante du
saint suaire en quelque sorte la
technique des lettres de plomb en relief
de l'imprimerie
c'est beaucoup mais les vraies cela
était vain qu'une nouvelle fois ce matin
en direct sur antenne 2 serge koenig
guide de haute montagne a gravi les
derniers des 8800 72 mètres par un vent
qui soufflait à 238 km un autre guide de
nid du crô va tenter le même exploit
avec une caméra d'antenne 2 jean monnet
voilà le sagarmatha vaincu ce matin par
serge koenig un sherpa
ils ont atteint le sommet par le col sud
en empruntant la voie normale cette fois
serge koenig a dépassé lente et 6 moules
étaient restés bloqués il y a deux ans
il a pu franchir les 80 m de dénivelé le
séparant du sommet une heure et demie
d'efforts intenses dans des conditions
épouvantables moins 25 degrés de
température extérieure et un vent
soufflant à près de 250 km heure
à des servites redescend vite
redescendre tout de suite redescente du
site
serge koenig est effectivement
redescendus il n'a pas heureusement les
pieds ni les mains gelées et il a
rejoint le pôle sud à 8000 m demain ce
sera au tour de denis du kroes le
caméraman de tenter l'ascension
caméra au poing comme si vous y étiez et
déjà bravo pour aujourd'hui et bon
courage pour demain alors les rapports
du tiercé qui s'est courue à evry
aujourd'hui donc à l'arrivée le 11 le 5
9 5 francs dans l'ordre rapporte 3976
francs 50 et dans un ordre différent 671
fond ne manquez pas ce soir à 22h15
résistance consacré à l'héritage de
l'esclavagé en afrique avec notamment un
superbe et terrifiant portage sur le
soudan vers 23h30 henri sannier vous
présentera notre dernière édition du
journal dans un instant laurent cabrol
qui va vous parler du temps merci
d'avoir suivi cette édition à demain 20
heures
ah ah